Welcome to "Ear Biscuits",
the podcast where two
lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're gonna plan the perfect
day for the other person.
Yeah, and we-
I'm gonna plan your perfect day, Rhett.
And I'm gonna plan your perfect day.
And just so you know,
we have committed to not
having planned it yet, so-
'Cause we were both like,
this wasn't our idea.
I think this was like the,
somebody from the Mythical crew suggested
that we do an episode where
we planned a perfect day for each other.
You know, if you guys
are such good friends,
you should be able to do that.
Yeah.
And then we're like, man,
do we wanna do this episode?
I don't wanna sit here
and think about planning
a day for you, especially if
I'm not gonna actually do it.
And so that's when I say-
And you're like-
Hey.
You know what?
This will be a fun exercise
to literally come up
with it in the moment.
Yes.
So I have kept myself
from thinking about your perfect day.
But I'm gonna tell you right now,
by the end of this episode,
you will have a perfect day plan
that you can tap into at any time.
Well, I'd be really good at
planning my own perfect day.
Well, that's the-
Can I just do that?
That's the,
well, we need to talk about
the ground rules for that.
But we've got some other things
to update everybody on
before we get to that.
Yeah.
I wanted to give an update on the party,
on the Mythical Christmas
party, which happened in-
Spring.
But 'cause I built that up,
we were talking about how, okay,
we're gonna do it that night.
And we gotta say that
we have a phone number.
We have an "Ear Biscuits" phone number.
We tweeted this out.
Yes.
But we wanna-
Very excited about this.
Just wanna let you know.
We wanted to make it where
not only could you tweet
and use hashtag ear
biscuits to give feedback
on the show and also to respond to prompts
that we put out there.
But we say, you know what?
We wanna be able to hear your voices.
It's like an old school radio show, man.
It's like calling in.
So 1-888-EARPOD1.
1-888-EARPOD1.
The number one.
Now we're gonna use this
number for a couple of things.
Now when we do a prompt
where we like, hey,
we wanna hear your stories about this
or your perspective on this,
we're gonna use that number.
Which that's what we're
gonna do next week.
We already-
We've already put out that prompt.
We've already tweeted that prompt.
If you wanna see it,
you can go over there.
Now-
But that,
next episode we're gonna do that.
Just because of the way
that the timing works
with when we record these
and when we do those prompts,
those prompts are most often
gonna be on Twitter, right?
So you need to be following
Mythical on Twitter
if you wanna see those prompts
and then you can be like,
I can call the number
and leave my message,
and then we might use it on an episode.
Now one of the things some
people have talked about,
I saw some people say,
"I don't wanna do this
'cause I don't like calling
numbers or I don't like,
I think it's a generational thing.
They don't call numbers anymore.
And they don't want their
voice to be heard somewhere-
Because it puts you on
the spot. I have an idea.
Okay.
You could record a voice memo
on your phone of what you wanna say.
And then you could, and you could do it
until you get it how you want it.
And then whenever you call in,
you have to use a second phone.
You gotta have a burner phone.
And then you gotta play the
message from your other phone.
I don't know if you can call a number
and play a voice memo at the same time.
You can probably do that-
I don't think that works.
You can play it from your computer,
assuming you have a computer
or you have a person with another phone.
Or you can just practice.
Or you know what? Don't worry about it.
Like we just talk off top of our heads
and like if things come sideways,
we won't make fun of you.
Yeah.
I promise we're not gonna make fun of you.
Should I have promised that?
Yeah. And so that's
how we're gonna use it.
You got another solution?
But we're, no, no. I
was gonna say you could-
Learn how to use the phone.
You could do that thing
where like you type
it in and then like the robot reads it,
if you really wanna do it.
But I would just say, hey-
We're not gonna choose that.
Use this as an opportunity to be like,
hey, I'm gonna overcome this fear
and I'm gonna leave a voice message
if that's a fear of yours.
And we'll, hey, we're accepting
dudes and it'll be okay.
The second thing we're gonna-
We're accepting all
people, not just dudes.
We are accepting dudes,
as in the two of us are accepting dudes.
Yeah, we are.
The other thing we're gonna use
the number for is any time,
anything that you want,
you have a question for us
that's completely unrelated to something
that we talked about, you have
a comment about something,
you have a thought about
something that we said,
something we got wrong,
something we need to correct,
a perspective on something,
maybe we'll listen to that and be like,
hey, somebody left a message about that.
And then at some point later,
we'll go back and address that, so-
I like this. Audio reactions to episodes.
You could, yeah.
You can do whatever you
want to on this line.
But I would just say keep it-
Short.
Relatively brief, or brief.
Not even relatively brief because it will
up the chances that we hear it and use it.
Yeah, that's right.
I mean, speaking of feedback, you know,
we're seeing feedback on the last episode.
It's like, man, you guys keep,
enough with the friendship talk
and then there's people like,
I love the friendship episodes.
And so it's, you know,
I get it. I get both.
I actually favored it on Twitter.
Some feedback that was like,
I'm tired of regurgitating
all these friendship stories.
It's kind of boring to me.
Well, and I, you know
what, I honestly, I'm kind-
It's something we've discussed.
I'm on team I'm tired of it too .
And so, because I, you
know, I think I'd love
for us to be able to
talk about topical things
and just hypothetical things
and answer your questions
or hear your perspectives on things.
I actually think today's episode is,
even though it's not
exactly in that category,
but it's this, it's an
exercise in us trying
to figure out how to plan the
perfect day for each other,
which it's a, to me,
it reminds me of an old
school rabbit hole episode
where we would just take
something and run with it.
The fact that we have not thought
about it and talked
about it ahead of time,
there's no preview and
we haven't even worked
it out on our own, to me,
this is the kind of thing
I get excited about.
To me, I get excited about variety.
And if you go back to the same well,
which is like maybe our shared experiences
from the past too much,
especially in a formatted way,
then yeah, I, you know, we
can get kind of bored with it.
So yeah, we appreciate the feedback.
We're kind of on the same page
already and just like saying,
hey, we wanna mix things up.
You wanna have the light, fun episodes.
I mean, what, one of
the problems with that,
just a little inside
baseball is that like,
when your show's not just one thing,
it's harder to promote
and for new audience
to come in and we want people to discover
"Ear Biscuits" and like
be folded into the fold.
But it's like, if it's
just the two of us talking
about our past or about anything,
it's like, it's kind
of hard to understand.
You really gotta give it some time.
So, you know, you're special because
you've given it the
time, you're committed,
we appreciate that.
And we want to hear from you. 188-EARPOD.
One.
Also, leave us, if you want,
there's something you wanna
hear us talk about, you know,
anything you want, and also do
that with hashtag ear biscuits,
because we are still
reading all those things.
Yeah.
So.
Multiple options.
So we built up, we were
recording a podcast
and then we were going to
the party in our parking lot.
You had on your DJ suit.
That night.
I had on my DJ suit.
And I was like, yeah, I'm,
I'd worked up some playlists,
'cause somebody had to do it,
and I really love that.
And you told me that, 'cause you,
it's interesting for someone
who is an aspirational DJ,
your sort of approach with a party
is that the music is not too loud.
Like, you can still have a conversation.
And then multiple times,
in multiple settings
over the past few years,
I've heard you legitimately
say people don't,
like, people don't like to dance, right?
Like you'll be like-
Well-
People don't,
like people, no one's
gonna want to dance, right?
Every playlist that I've made
is for a party that usually,
I've had at my house where it's like-
Old people.
We're just hanging out and we're talking,
we're catching up, we're
having some libations.
We're chilling out by the fire
pit. We're taking it easy.
It's a kickback vibe.
Yeah.
And-
You're very good at those playlists.
The party.
And I already had a couple
of those playlists cooked up,
but then I had this sneaking suspicion
in the back of my mind
that it was gonna be
a little too laid back, and I said that.
But we get to the party and it's,
we had a couple of food trucks,
we had tables set out,
and then people are getting
their like Korean barbecue.
And there's like the vegan food truck
and hey, options for everybody.
We're accepting dudes.
And then we're accepting all people and-
Vegan's included.
They all came to the party.
It was like the first
outdoor unmasked thing
that everybody could be at.
I was like, people are
gonna want to connect.
They're gonna meet for the first time.
We had the name tags
so that people like me with name fright
would be like, hey, I know who you are
'cause you've written it on your person.
Yeah.
And people are, and I'm playing-
I got cute with that
and put Brett on mine.
That's cute.
Yeah.
And so I was playing my
kickback, instrumentals playlist.
No lyrics, nothing to
interfere with conversation,
but a nice, just mid-tempo vibe
to eat some barbecue and
sit down and talk to people.
I'm like, man, this is going good.
There's a little bit
of mingling happening.
We're having a good time.
Everybody's eating.
And then that took a, you know,
an hour and 1/2, maybe two hours.
And then we gave a speech.
And I don't know, it always seems like
you know what you wanna say
and I'm like, don't know,
and I hadn't even thought
about it, but I'm here for it
and I'm glad to be speaking.
But not knowing what I'm trying to convey.
Hey, that's a great one, two punch, man.
So yeah. So one, two punch.
I didn't really know what
I was gonna say until right before.
Don't say that. That makes me feel worse.
But-
But you did think about it at some point.
I thought about it.
Like it was, I thought about it in points.
It was like, I have three points.
Do you remember the points?
No.
Anyway, I mean, come on.
They would, they'd love
to hear your speech.
Like paraphrased.
Wow. Okay.
Jenna, you might have to help
with this if it was without memorable.
You think Jenna remembers your speech?
Yeah. She was too many libations.
Don't throw Jenna under the bus.
It was early in the evening.
We were all with it.
I think I said something like,
it's great to be back together
to see the bottom half of your faces.
Yeah.
That community is such a big part
of what we have built here,
and there's something about being together
and actually being in
the same physical space,
and I'm just so excited
that we're able to do this.
It was about-
Yeah.
I tapped into the community aspect
of what we were experiencing.
And I was like, what he said.
You kind of took it all.
I can't remember what I said.
I think I said I love all of you.
There was some kind of joke about,
I put my hand on your shoulder.
And I said, I was like,
you know, sometimes,
and I put my hand on your shoulder
like sometimes if you
come into our office,
this, we do this when
we are like, it was a,
there was an impromptu moment
where there was something
about there was a joke.
There was a joke about
when we're struggling
and we're depending on each other.
And we might come into our
office and we're doing this.
And then like you turned and we did that.
We did like a physical joke.
Yeah.
And then I made an HR joke,
which I hate making HR jokes.
We always tend to make a-
But Ellen was there.
And so I was just like,
if you are gonna touch
someone on the shoulders,
check with Ellen first or
something like that, you know.
I don't like to make those jokes.
And I wouldn't have made
that joke if I had really,
see, this is why I plan things.
Because when you don't plan things,
you end up making that
joke and everybody laughed
and everybody knew it
was, you know, harmless,
and we're talking about shoulder touching.
And I made the one thing
I do remember saying was the phrase,
now we're gonna kick
this party up a notch.
So-
I don't know what,
remember I said something
like that and I don't know-
You were feeling it.
I don't know.
This is a natural DJ instinct.
Yeah, I don't know why I said
that because I wasn't thinking.
I was-
You were like, I'm not
prepared to kick it up a notch.
No, I was thinking I had a playlist
that was gonna take it up like one notch.
Okay. So what-
So then I started,
but then I wasn't ready to play it yet
because there were a few more
songs in my existing playlist.
Well, give me an example of
what the middle playlist was,
the taking it up at one notch.
Well, it had lyrics.
Okay.
So it was some-
It had lyrics.
It was some late '90s rap,
which I thought would connect.
Like Ice Cube's "Today Was A Good Day".
But still kinda like.
Yeah, still vibing.
We're all interacting with each other.
And, but I didn't change the playlist yet.
And I went back and sat down,
and Jenna leaned over and she said,
"Is this your idea of
kicking it up a notch?"
Jenna!
And I was like,
yeah, I don't know why
I said that prematurely
because I wasn't ready
to kick it up a notch.
Is this your idea of
kicking it up a notch?
And I was like, you know what?
I can do that. I can do that.
And I went over there and then
like, I started, I actually,
I think I went to use the bathroom.
I was like, I gotta compose myself.
And when I came back out,
Jenna said, I don't
think, she came up to me.
And it was like a little, like,
I'm whispering even though
there's no one around.
Yeah. Right.
And she was like,
"People are coming up to
me because I don't think
that they're comfortable
coming up to you."
I love this.
"And they're just asking,
could we have music with,
you know, with like lyrics?"
Okay.
The music already had a beat.
And then she was like, you know,
"I think people want to dance."
And I was like, people want to dance?
And I looked around at how everyone
there was younger than me.
Well-
And I was like,
you know what?
Significantly younger.
And I'm like, yeah, the
people who work here,
yeah, they're in a different head space.
When they want, I was like,
but they haven't seen
each other for so long.
So many people have never met.
Don't they just wanna sit down and talk?
And Jenna was like, "No."
We did it already.
We did it already. We've been doing that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I'm like, okay, okay.
Well, then I'm thinking my backup
to my backup playlist to
take it up a second notch
is still not taking us to the dance floor.
You weren't prepared for a dance party.
I wasn't prepared for a dance party.
And that was such a
huge blind spot for me.
Yeah. Well, every DJ's
gotta have that moment.
And a big wake up call.
This is gonna be in your DJ,
when you write your DJ autobiography,
this is gonna be called,
the chapter's gonna be
called wake up call,
and you're gonna tell this story.
Yeah, so then I go, you know,
I read Questlove's book and-
Did he have a wake up call?
He had a wake up call.
He tells this fantastic
story of how President Obama,
he was sitting president at the time,
invited him to an event.
And Questlove had been
working on a set list
for like months and months
and months leading up to this.
And it was like, go, it was
like this amazingly intricate,
like goes from A to B, goes
through the history of music.
And it's like this amazing,
intricate set list.
And then he's playing it for Obama.
This is like, this is
a big moment for him.
And then after a while,
President Obama pull,
comes up to him, pulls
him aside and you know,
he does an impression of
him and is basically like,
"Can you play something for the kids?
Can you play something for the kids?"
And that's my Obama, by the way.
That's pretty good.
And he was crushed.
He started, he had to start
googling on his phone.
I mean, Questlove, it's
not that he didn't know
what the kids would want to listen to.
Who, what kids, the Obama kids?
The younger people who were there.
The kids.
And then so like,
can you play some current hits, you know?
And so he like totally
off the, on the fly,
just had to regroup entirely.
Wow.
And then he had to start playing-
Wake up call, man.
Had to start playing
what the people wanted
to hear right then and dance to.
And then I think there's a part
of the story where he is like,
when it was all over, when
the party was over, he just,
he snuck away and just left.
And he said that he couldn't
DJ for like the year.
Oh my.
It was like a huge deal for him. And-
This is a much better story than yours.
I'm so grateful to hear
his much better story,
because then I was like, you know what?
I'm just, I don't even, I'm not a DJ.
I don't even have DJ equipment.
Yet.
I'm sitting here with a, with Spotify.
Hold on, but you're ready to get,
you are gonna buy some.
And then at this point,
I'm like, all right.
So I start kicking it up with what I know.
I'm playing some late '90s rap
and people are going on the dance floor.
And then I'm like, I'll take requests.
And then based on the first few requests,
I mean, these are songs that I knew of.
I was aware of them and
I would like find them
and put 'em in the queue.
And then I was like, I
hope people don't see this.
And then I like took those
songs and I started googling.
Like, I'm like, these people
like mid-2000's dance floor.
Hit the dance floor. Like,
I'm literally Googling this.
And then I'm over there like, yeah, okay.
And then I'm throwing
songs in the playlist.
And I'm like, okay, now I got this.
People are giving requests,
it's getting dark, everybody's
dancing. And you know what?
It started to work. It started to work.
It did.
I, the thing I was observing,
'cause I was not party to any of this.
I wasn't talking to,
I didn't talk to you other
than when we'd give a speech.
We tend to-
Yeah, yeah.
We tend to separate-
Right.
In glad hand separately.
Yeah.
We're too-
Divide and conquer.
We're too accepting
dudes. There's two of us.
Divide the party.
But the thing I noticed was
I hadn't seen the Mythical
crew together to that degree.
And we also had the Smash crew,
you know, in two years and-
Yeah.
We've hired a bunch of people
over the past two years
and you know, we keep getting older
and we keep hiring people who are younger.
And so there are just a lot of,
most people are in their 20s
and many of them are like
in their early and mid 20s, right?
Yeah.
And there's just a
different life stage, man.
And yeah, they wanna dance
and it was just like, it was amazing.
Once they started hearing
what they wanted to hear,
it was like a release and
it, and you know what-
It was like letting
people out of, you know,
they would've been like cooped up.
Yeah.
Socially.
And they were just letting loose.
And it was a beautiful thing to watch.
It did feel good to see
the Mythical crew and the
Smash crew come together
and hang out and have a good time,
and nobody wanted to leave the party.
They all just wanted to dance
or hang around the edge.
And it like, the party really took a turn.
Thank you, Jenna, for breaking the news.
Yes.
And I was like,
I went up to Christie and I was like,
"Yeah, this is, I've really
gotta make some adjustments."
She was like, "You can do it, babe."
She's like being very supportive.
And then so then yeah,
the party started jumping.
Yeah.
And I was like Googling
and taking requests
and figuring it out.
And people were like, looking at me like,
man, he's just taking
this really seriously.
Now can I get you, just as you're,
you know, I believe in
this career evolution.
I like the idea of your DJ phase.
You know, we're jokingly
calling you DJ Rhett,
but I honestly think
you need to, you know,
you really need to, are
you gonna be DJ Straw Beat?
You need to-
I don't like that either.
You know, whatever you're gonna be,
I mean, I think you need to take some time
and you need to figure that out.
DJ guy from the internet.
Yeah.
But like, I do have a
vision of you, you know,
us going to like parties and like,
yo, there's Link, he's, hell, Link's here
and DJ whatever is here
and he's doing his thing.
Now my only note at this point
is facial expression, okay?
So in that moment-
Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I think this is why-
This is good. Okay. I'll
take, I'm taking notes.
I think this is why-
Even on facial expression.
This is why, who are the two guys
that wear the helmets, the-
Daftpunk.
And then who's the guy
that wears the big mouse?
Deadmau5.
Marshmallow.
And then you got Marshmallow.
Yeah.
I know-
You're saying I need to,
Imma need a mask. Okay.
I wanna wear a mask of my,
of your face 'cause of DJ Rhett.
That's pretty funny.
Or wear a mask of my own face,
making the expression that apparently
you're about to tell me I need to make.
Well, the reason that they,
my theory is why they
wear helmets is because
it's very difficult to not
look like you're trying.
And you have a very, like,
there's a very specific face that you make
when you're concentrating and trying
and you kind of, you start,
you kind of go into like,
you look a little bit
like an old man trying
to figure something out, right?
You like this, like?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so whereas, I think
most, exactly, yeah, yeah.
Just like this?
Yeah, that's it.
And so I think that most cool DJs
either have a helmet or they found a way
to look super happy and effortless
the whole time that
everything is happening.
So I don't, I'm not telling
you what you should do.
Well, I was, at the beginning,
are you talking about at the beginning
or like once I got in?
Like once it was like, I recovered.
I'm saying you-
Even in the recovery, there
was like the old man thing.
I, well, I, when you would look down,
there would be like a crinkle of the,
there would be a crinkle of
the brow, there would be,
I mean, the person who pointed
this out to me was your wife.
So I'm sitting with Jesse
and Christie and she's like,
"Look at him. He's trying so hard."
And I looked and I was like-
I was, man.
This guy is, he's doing a good job,
but he doesn't look like
he's doing a good job.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
You gotta, it's kinda like in the,
when we, in the book in the gallery,
we're talking about confidence.
It's all about the look on your face.
Yeah, yeah.
You're exactly right. What Imma do-
Mask is not a bad idea.
So I learned so much that night
and this is the last piece of the puzzle
because I derived so many
things that why you need,
a DJ needs equipment.
So like when you're just
using a Spotify playlist,
you are not a DJ because I would look
at the dance floor and be all right,
this song is too long,
this song needs to end,
and the next song needs to go ahead
and play and it needs to blend,
but the next song needs
to start after the intro.
I had no capability to do any of that.
So that's what the
equipment allows you to do.
Yeah, if you,
you can't even cross
fade songs using Spotify,
unless you let them play to completion
and then the next one
starts to completion.
You can't do it manually.
In order to make a transition,
you had to stop the song
and start the next one,
and I was trying to do that.
I was like driving what it meant
to be a DJ as if no one had ever done it.
I do believe there was one time
in which a song kind of abruptly ended
and you said, "Sorry."
Yeah.
Yeah, I did have a microphone.
And a couple of requests were like
the worst thing to play at that moment.
And I was like, I would
call the person out
and be like, "Hey, this is on so and so.
This is not my decision."
So I learned like, you can't
take requests all the time-
Man, this is like a crash
course in deejaying.
That was like throwing
myself to the wolves.
Yeah. Right.
Yeah.
But now I'm realizing,
so I, after that night,
I ordered a DJ deck.
I now-
You ordered one?
I already have it.
Really?
Yeah.
Last weekend, I set the thing
up and in my living room
and I had the headphones
and I was using my speakers
and I stayed up until
like 2:30 in the morning
just pretending to be deejaying
a party that nobody was at.
I love this. I love it.
And you know what? It was so much fun.
Is it a software? Like how
does it? Do you load the songs?
It's Serato DJ. DJ Lite is free.
And then it connects to the board,
which like simulates two turntables.
But where is it getting the music from?
You can connect it with
Tidal or SoundCloud.
So I had to get a Tidal subscription.
So you're playing like the high res stuff?
I'm playing the high res stuff.
And you know what, I wasn't doing it to,
yes, I was pretending to
be at a party kind of,
and like, thinking about
my experience and like,
what would I've done if I
would have had this equipment?
Yeah, I would have done this.
This is what I wanted to do.
This is how I would
want to mix these songs.
And it's like, I haven't
really figured it out yet.
But it, the main thing is it's like,
it's an exercise in active listening.
I mean, for the whole pandemic,
I really got into listening
to music voraciously,
like, and making playlists.
That's where this whole thing started.
And so this is like another
level of it's active listening
and you're like participating in it
and there's like, there's
knobs and it's very tangible.
And like you're learning software
and there's a really big part of this
that is about control, you know-
Right. Yeah.
Which obviously resonates
with my proclivities
to like say, okay, can I control people's
and react to people's responses
and give them a good time?
Like, I love this. I really
think this may be my calling.
Well, interesting that you
say that because, you know,
and I think this is a good channeling
of that because it is true.
Like, oftentimes if we're
like in a group setting,
you know, my wife is the one
that will point this out to you sometimes.
It's like, okay, Link, you
feel like you're trying to-
she'll bring something
up and you'll be like,
"I don't wanna talk about that."
You don't say that, but you indicate
that you don't wanna talk
about that right now.
You're kind of trying to keep
the conversational flow according
to what you think we
should be talking about.
Yeah.
But I think that this is a way
for you to exercise some control
in a way that serves the group
in a way that no one else is going to do.
Right.
And you can like control the vibe of the,
of a party without controlling
the conversation of a party.
But it is a conversation.
I mean, it's not just control one way.
It's a two-way streak
'cause you gotta read it.
You gotta read the room.
Yeah.
But now I'm realizing the one other piece
that I need for my DJ setup is a mirror.
To check your teeth?
No, just to check the look on my face.
Like, I'm gonna put a mirror down here.
Lando makes fun of me.
He says, "Every time
you look in the mirror
and fix your hair, dad, you
make a, you make this face."
Yeah.
I'm like, no, I don't.
I mean, I-
I'm like, yeah, I think I do.
I'm-
So yeah, if I had a mirror there,
I'd be making this face all the time.
Well, I'm be honest about this.
I feel like it would be super cool.
And maybe, I don't know,
I'm not throwing anything
out there, but maybe I am.
You could get the Mythical
Beasts to help out with this.
But like, I think there's an opportunity
to achieve some sort of persona, you know,
like some name and maybe there is like,
okay, he always wears suits.
You know, he's always got
matching tops and bottoms.
And he, this is his helmet.
This is what's on his head.
I mean, this, I'm just saying there's,
the possibilities are pretty limitless.
And I never understood it.
I never understood the
helmets in the mouse head
and the Marshmallow until this moment.
And now it's all making
sense to me that like-
I think I can, I don't
wanna wear a helmet.
Just could probably hide in there.
Probably hide.
Well, you can get a cooled,
one that has built-in cooling.
Wow.
Yeah.
Or, you know, or you
could just learn the face.
What about just a hat?
It could be a hat.
But I'm saying like, you gotta
have a name 'cause right,
Because this DJ Rhett thing
is kind of catching on now
and you gotta stop that from happening.
Yeah. That can-
I think.
That can't happen. That can't happen.
Right.
It can't happen.
This can't be your thing
when you have nothing to do with it.
It's like become front
and center of the thing.
I mean, it's pretty funny.
It is funny.
But it's a chapter in the
book, the DJ Rhett days.
And yeah, as long as I
suck, I can be called that.
Right.
And then like when I realize that, okay,
I think I've got something
to offer to the world
and I gotta come out with my real name.
Yeah. Yeah.
But you put some thought into that
because then you could act
different and everything.
It's like different I'm showing up-
Alter ego.
I'm showing up as this guy.
Yeah.
And.
I could wear matching suits,
and which is kind of what I already did.
Right. That's what I'm saying.
Yeah. You're laying the
groundwork for this.
I could wear overalls.
And, but I do think that you're
gonna have to bring Jenna-
Coveralls?
Jenna every time.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Because she's gonna have to be figuring
out what the people-
Somebody come up whisper-
Whisper it to you.
Whisper the-
Well, I think she'll have a,
you'll have an earpiece in your helmet
and she'll have a little microphone.
Jenna, you'll be like, the
face, work on the face.
You're doing that face again.
You're doing the old man face.
Okay. Well, we haven't
even planned our days.
Thank you for indulging me.
That was the update on the party.
I didn't mean to make it all
about me and my DJ experience.
But everybody had a good time.
We, when, when we were,
nobody wanted to leave.
Yeah. I mean, I-
You left.
I ducked out about-
I kept playing music-
8:30 or so.
And then because I did this trick
where I kept playing music
and then everyone who stayed,
we got them to help clean up.
Well, I knew that was
gonna happen so I left.
Yeah.
No, I left because I did my little dance.
You know, and my dancing has gotten
much more reserved over the
years with my back situation.
So I did my little dance in the circle
and then I popped out and then I was like,
okay, you know, you kids have fun.
Daddy's going home to go to sleep.
But my, yeah, my idea is I'm
a, I wanna be a barbecue DJ.
I'm still more of a, I'm
more of a laid back mode.
I'm not like, I'm not going to the club.
That is not my aspiration. I
want to go to the barbecue.
Okay.
I like to have it,
I want to have it a
little bit more laid back.
But I can't, but I'd like,
but I need to have it in my repertoire
to hit the dance floor.
Man, we waited a long
time to do our promo.
It usually comes earlier.
What are we promoting today?
Here, Rhett, read this script.
This is a promotion that involves you.
Before we get to the rest of the episode,
we wanted to tell you about
an exciting upcoming episode
of "Best Friends Back, Alright".
All right.
Now we talked about "BFBA"
a few times on the show.
Yes, we have.
The show where Stevie
and Neagheen reconnect
after 15 years apart.
And this week, there's something-
It's a great show.
A little different.
On this Friday's episode,
I, Rhett, not DJ Rhett,
just Rhett, will be guesting
on the show and talking
to Stevie And Neagheen
about everyone's favorite
high school period, lunchtime.
It's not periods.
I think they've already
talked about periods.
I'm sure they have.
They're just talking about
their favorite, like lunchtime.
The favorite high school period.
Search for "Best Friends Back, Alright"
on your favorite podcast
app or click the link
in the episode description to follow
so you don't miss Friday's episode.
While you're over there, check out some
of the other incredible
episodes of the podcast.
I wonder if Neagheen is gonna hate you.
No, I know me.
I kind of hope Neagheen
hates you by the end of it.
That would be hilarious to listen to.
We get along great.
I'm gonna listen to see
if Neagheen hates Rhett.
Okay.
All right.
Let's plan the perfect
day for the other guy.
The only thing I've thought
about is a few ground rules.
You know, me, I love rules.
That was a joke.
I think that this is something is,
should be something that is like possible.
Yeah. Yeah. Let's keep it. Let's keep-
It's something that we could do.
Feasible. Yeah.
It's a feasible thing.
We're talking, and what are we talking,
12 hours or 24 hours?
I think we should stick with the day.
I think this is like, when you wake up
and when you go to bed.
So it could be a little
bit longer than normal.
Okay. Okay.
I also don't think that,
I don't think it can
involve any extensive travel
because that's not a great day.
Like it's-
It's gotta be really justified.
I'm gonna fly you to Hawaii.
Well, yeah. What about
that five-hour flight?
You gotta fly back too.
That sucks. Yeah. Right.
It wouldn't work.
You gotta, you have to
wake up in your own bed
and go to sleep in your own bed.
So I think that rules
out extensive travel.
Yeah. It's just a day.
It's not an overnight trip.
And this is something that if we so chose,
we could implement and actually pull off.
Snap.
So it's not like,
well, I'm gonna get, you know,
I'm gonna get Questlove to come
and give you a personalized DJ lesson.
Yeah.
'Cause that would be super cool,
but I just don't know
if I can pull that off.
I don't, yeah. He wouldn't
sniff the hole on Fallon.
I tried to get him to sniff the-
Right, I remember that.
Get him to smell the hole.
He said no.
Of the cinnamon roll.
Yeah. So I think it's
gotta be something that-
I didn't get to talk to him afterward.
You know that like, if
I'm planning your thing,
I know that I could do it if
I wanted to and vice versa.
Yeah. Okay. All right. Yeah. Yeah.
Doesn't involve any maybes or what if.
It's, this is actually could happen.
Okay. All right.
And it doesn't necessarily
have to involve the other guy.
You could just be like a concierge for me.
You don't have to be there.
If it's, if the idea
is better without you,
then you've gotta be
willing to not be there.
Right? 'Cause that, it's my perfect day.
It's not our perfect day.
Well, that might put a little bit of a,
because one of the things
that I'm thinking about-
Hey, I'm just saying
it could go either way.
Well, you remember that time I-
I have the freedom of disinviting you.
I picked you and your
girlfriend at the time up.
Yeah.
And took you on a date,
and I turned my Dodge
Dynasty into a limousine.
And the only thing I did was I put
a sheet up between the
front and back seats.
Yeah.
And I put on a hat and I
used an English accent.
Yeah, I, and I, you know
what, pardon my French,
but I would call that boss.
I mean, yeah.
She was a little uncomfortable
because it was like-
To have your best friend
take you on a date.
Yeah.
Like to go on a date with a guy
and then his best friend
is acting like a chauffer
and has a sheet up
between you and the front.
You were in character the whole time.
It was very much about you.
Yeah, I was putting on a show,
and I took you to like a jazz.
You remember that jazz
themed restaurant in-
At Waverley Place.
Waverley Place?
And Carrie.
Yeah.
I mean, I booked the reservations.
Yeah, I didn't plan the, unlike now.
But I, do you think it was my idea
or your idea to do that?
I think I probably pitched it.
Yeah, what if I, you know,
you wanna do something really nice,
let's get her a limo driven by me.
And it's not a limo, it's the
Dynasty. I'll put a sheet up.
I'll use an English accent
because I'll chauffeurs are from England.
Just a little insight
into my 16-year-old mind.
We just saw it from the perspective
of this is hilarious and awesome and cool.
But from her perspective was, like,
yeah, this is a bit uncomfortable.
And I mean, strangely third wheelish.
But also this is what you get
when you were, you're dating Link.
Yeah. You get a-
Rhett might show up as your chauffer.
You don't know what's gonna happen.
So I, anyway, all that to say-
So did you wanna start? Go.
I'm gonna be your chauffeur for the day.
Okay. All right.
Just, and I will be
using an English accent.
And I, you know what?
Yeah. It's weird. That's
weird. It's gonna be weird.
Go ahead.
Okay. I'm just saying I
can, okay, do you want-
You're gonna pick me up at what time?
Well.
What's the first thing?
Well, first thing is, I'm going to,
the day before, I'm going to
learn your smoothie recipe,
'cause I know you gotta
make your smoothie,
but does the process
of making the smoothie,
is that part of it-
It's starting to feel a little bit
too much like Mother's Day.
Like, you know, it's
like, this seems like a-
You have to start your
day with the damn smoothie
so I figured that's part of it.
This is like a, yeah, I just think,
give me time to make my own smoothie.
So okay.
Really?
My perfect day is I make my own smoothie.
You make your own smoothie?
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
So you, before you pick me up, apparently.
So this is gonna be the,
I could do anything.
This is the perfect day.
I've perfected my smoothie.
It's the perfect start of the day.
I drink my coffee, I drink my
smoothie, and I take a poop.
And if I do those three things-
I don't wanna be there for that.
Then I'm like, you know
what? I'm ready to go.
I've gotten the nutrients
and I'm cleaned out.
I'm ready to go.
Okay.
This-
So you don't even have
to worry about breakfast.
Okay. So I'm picking you up.
But the question is, your family with you?
Like, are you like, 'cause
I feel like the perfect day.
My kids? Hell no.
Okay. So the kids are not-
That's a joke, but at this point,
I'm, I was assuming that no.
I definitely think that the kids,
I mean, I think about my kids.
I think there might be a certain point
where they show up for a
window of time for something.
But the fact is is that
I love my children,
but I'm gonna see them the next day.
Right.
And they're only,
they only have potential to
screw up the perfect day.
I hate, you know, I hate to
say that about them publicly.
I love them both.
'Cause your perfect day-
But teenagers-
Puts them in a position
where they're not having
their perfect day.
You know that messes up your perfect day.
When you ask teenagers like,
dad's having his perfect day.
Right.
And they're like, crap.
We gotta be a part of it?
You know, we gotta be there for this?
And then they've got a
little bit of attitude.
Yeah. Like for Mother's Day,
and I know you did this too.
Like, we had like six or seven-hour window
of time where it was like,
we went to an event that
Christie wanted to go to
and we went out to lunch afterward.
But like that event that we went
to with all these shops
that Christie went to,
it was like me and Lincoln and Lando
were just kind of following her around
and trying to keep a smile
on our face while she enjoyed herself.
Mother's Day.
But it's like, and she was
glad that we were there,
but 'cause it was Mother's Day.
But if it was just her perfect day,
she probably would've
preferred to be shopping
at those shops and then
meet up with us later.
So yeah, no harm, no foul here.
My wife got back from
our Mother's Day outing
and she said that might have been
the best Mother's Day I've ever had.
Yeah. But how, and how was
it for you and the boys?
I mean you, so we went
over to Santa Monica,
went over to the West
Side, had a little brunch
at a place that's right
there on the beach.
That's good, brunch.
And then we drove over to Abbott Kinney.
Nice shops.
And we just kind of-
Expensive.
We went up and down and it was more
like Jessie's going where she wants to go
and we may go in with her or
we may go to another place.
And then we'll kind of this roving thing-
Yeah, that's good.
Where we kind of up with her.
Yeah.
And so, and I think that the
boys had a pretty good time.
They got, you know, got,
get some pizza and stuff.
We were there. We basically
stayed out all day.
That's cool. Now for me, no shopping.
Like, don't, I don't wanna go shopping.
Okay. So I pick you up.
What time you wanna be picked up?
Probably 7:30, 8 o'clock.
Eight o'clock.
For your, you know, you
don't wanna waste a day.
Now, I mean, besides the travel required
to get across town, I, we've
had some pretty good days
that have started with surfing.
Yeah. We haven't done that in a while.
It's just we're just kind of,
we're far away from the ocean.
Yeah. Yeah. I'd like to do that.
Now you never know what you're gonna get-
Might get hurt.
With a surfing day.
Yeah, it could be a dud.
But I would say that, I mean,
I'm not putting in requests,
but for me, I think beginning
the day would, you know-
That's what, you know what?
I'm actually changing.
All right.
You're planting the seat.
All right, we'll go surfing on your day.
But here's the thing.
I'm gonna rent you a oceanfront
house so you wake up.
Wow.
Now we did this. I don't know when it was.
In the middle of the pandemic
when we were just having
a hell of a time trying
to be a family during the
pandemic and having kids
that were just so
frustrated with not going
to school and you know,
not seeing their friends,
my therapist who happens
to be my wife's therapist
as well was like, "Hey, you
guys really just need to like,
go get change of scenery, right?"
And we ended up, we rented a place.
We haven't been in LA for-
I remember this.
For 11 years
and had, have never done this,
but we rented like a one
of those places, small,
but like on the water in
Malibu where the water,
the waves are hitting the house at night.
That's nice.
I don't know about the owner
and I don't know what you do
when the waves eventually take it down,
but hey, I'll rent it for a little bit.
And I brought my paddle board
and it was literally like,
you would just, you could just
wake up, go down some steps,
you were on the beach, and
then you're in the water.
Like it that's a, that was a
great way to start the day.
So I'm gonna rent a beachfront
condo or a place for you.
But since this is our perfect day.
Our perfect day.
Well, like, we probably
should both rent that
and spend the night
there the night before.
Well, now, you got us
starting in your own bed.
That's what you said.
Crap. Why did I make that
rule? Can I change it?
But it's just for the day.
So it's a little splurgy but yeah,
you gotta home base so
you can get off the beach
and you can shower and you can have
as many Topa Chicas as you want.
I mean, I'm not saying, I'm
not requesting anything,
but, and then you move on to
the next thing fully showered.
Wash the sand out your butt cheeks.
Okay, so at this point, I
feel like we're pretty on,
I feel like my perfect day
and your perfect day are kind
of in line at this point. I'm-
Well-
I don't have a smoothie routine.
Yeah, I think yours is so
much, is gonna be a lot,
is gonna be pretty food-centric.
I think you're gonna care about breakfast,
but we're gonna be in a hurry.
So you're gonna wanna go
through the McDonald's drive through
and get a sausage and egg McGriddles.
Well, am I just accepting
what you're suggesting?
That's what I, yep.
So we're going through the
McDonald's drive through
and getting a McGriddles.
We're not doing a sit down breakfast
because boy, what I have in
store for your perfect day,
you're not gonna want to delay.
Okay. So I get a McGriddles.
Yeah. Yeah.
You love it, man.
I mean-
It's a splurge. I mean,
it's like a caloric splurge.
It's rare to have something
better than a McGriddles.
Right.
Even at like some sit down
breakfast place, yeah,
you don't, you think you
want it, but you don't.
You might have been thinking like-
Thought I did.
What did you think you wanted?
Well, I was gonna say that-
Just say it.
I was gonna say that-
Typically, a perfect
day for me is two meals.
Like if I go home-
All right, no food, no breakfast.
Well, if I go-
You're gonna be hungry
and we're gonna eat lunch at like one
and you're gonna be starving,
it's gonna be so good.
No lunch. When I go on vacation-
All right, so you brunch and dinner.
We eat brunch and dinner.
Well, listen-
Like really big brunches
and really big dinners.
No, that's, it sucks up too
much time to eat a really-
What? But that's what I wanna do.
It's not what you want.
I love eating and I love
going to cool places to eat.
You wanna go to-
I don't like,
I don't want like my mom to
come and like cook for me
like if that's what you're asking.
I love her cooking,
but like, I like going
to a restaurant, man.
All right, fine.
But we're, I mean, we
going after the physical,
we're gonna go surfing, and then the-
There's a physical?
Your perfect day has to
start with a physical.
What? I gotta turn and cough.
No, you gotta, I'm gonna drop you off.
I'm gonna make a special,
the first appointment
they've got at the doctor.
To make sure I can go?
I just want you to be fully checked out.
Like I just, you know, you
never get around to it.
You never get around to it.
No, no, no. I've been fully checked out.
And you need to be thoroughly checked out.
I'm not gonna get a
physical on my perfect day.
Like, yeah, this is the
most, this sounds horrible.
Think about it. Dude,
you're a hypochondriac.
You wanna be cleared.
You wanna be cleared at the beginning
of the day to be like, you know what?
They've tested me for my
blood, my semen, everything.
I can prep for this.
I can do a blood test and a physical
and a semen test like
a week ahead of time.
No, because what happens in that week?
And I ain't talking about COVID here.
I'm talking about much,
much worse than that.
Okay. Let me-
I'm talking about cancer.
Can I just say that, so-
I'm thinking of your best, man.
So far, I've, I'm chauffer you around,
renting you a beach house in Malibu.
And what you've done for me
is you got me in
McGriddles and a physical.
I can't. Yeah, man. I know the real you.
Like, you're gonna be so freed up.
The McGriddles is a good idea.
After that physical.
Listen, the physical is unnecessary.
Like, when that doctor
comes out and is like,
"Listen, man, I can, nothing.
You're totally clean."
Tell me about this doctor.
He's smart. He knows this stuff.
It's a he? It's not even
like a hot female doctor.
What do you, I mean, it's not-
If you're gonna make me do a physical,
at least I need to find like a little,
something needs to be fun.
No, man, the fun is being
cleared of all worry. You're-
But like I get anxiety at the doctor.
I get, I have white coat
blood pressure issues.
So I just don't think this is a,
this is not getting me
in the right mind space.
And if they do find something,
then it becomes like
your last day on earth.
Like it's like, you know
what? I got bad news.
You have one day to live,
but it's like, well, good.
You know what? This is your perfect day.
Perfect. It's a win-win.
Okay, let me get back to
what I'm doing for you.
So you get done with your surfing session.
Right there, I get into
the bungalow, shower.
Well, hold on.
I plan this in such a way
as you never know if
the surf's gonna be good
and sometimes you can have
a great time regardless,
but we're talking, I'm gonna plan this
on a day when it's like
the waves are consistent.
It's smooth and glassy, not too big,
so you're not gonna get hurt
and you just have those,
you know, we've had a
couple of days like that
and it's just a great
way to start the day.
Being on the water is a
victory. It doesn't matter.
Well, I'm saying, I'm planning
this on a day when there's good surf.
Then you come back into the house
and I have hired just one of these
like really good yoga people.
You know what I'm saying?
Maybe like just a masseuse.
Well, hold on.
Yeah, but the masseuse is part of it too.
But this is a person who
is like super comforting
and relaxing guru like who,
after you come in and do whatever
you need to do shower wise,
they've created this environment
in this Malibu place where there,
it's like super soothing and there's like
this awesome playlist playing.
No, you know what? I'm going
all out. It's not a playlist.
It is a live-
Flutist.
It's a live band that
plays like spa music.
I don't wanna band watching me do yoga.
They're not. They're all
turned away from you.
They're all turned into the corner. Okay?
They're just there. Maybe
they're in the next room.
This is strange.
No, no, no. They're-
I feel strange.
And there's like, they there's like.
They make like, they make
the kind of things that you,
the kind of noises that you
hear in this yoga music,
but it's all live and they're doing that-
A live sound bath.
And this is a person of your choice.
I mean, I can give you a list of,
I've got multiple people
'cause I know how you are
with people sometimes.
And so I've given you like,
I've hired four yoga instructors.
And I'm supposed to look at
'em and choose one of 'em?
No, no.
They are on the other side
of a one-way mirror that I've installed.
So they know they're being?
No, no, no.
I tell them something like,
hey, this is a fun game I'm playing-
You've been accused of a crime.
They're like, this is a fun game I play
with my friend where I'm
paying you full price
for your day, all four of you,
but only one of you is gonna
be chosen because it's a,
he comes from a weird
religion where he has to pick.
It feels a little brothely.
Okay.
So you just want me to
pick the person for you,
because you might have
a problem with them.
Just.
I don't like their voice.
You know, I want you
to be able to see them.
I appreciate what you're trying to do.
And then choose them.
And then, okay, well, just say somehow,
you choose that person.
The band's going, they're
doing their sounds.
They come in and they lead you through
just a really relaxing-
Vinyasa.
Stretching,
little meditation.
Very, very good stuff.
Okay.
And then that moves into,
here comes a person.
They set up a table and ask
you to disrobe and get on it.
Right?
This is the massage part.
And what we do is-
Is this the exam? Mine's just later.
This is a, you thought you were wild
with a four-hander, this
is a six hand massage.
So I'm talking three people,
doesn't have to be three women.
In fact, it probably shouldn't be based
on how your four-hander
went with two women.
Yeah.
So we've got three-
I think it should be very inclusive.
Okay. So you want two women,
one man, what do you want?
I just, it makes me uncomfortable.
I don't know why I've
kind of positioned myself
as a pimp in your day.
I know. I know.
It's like-
It's like, this is not good.
It's like, I don't wanna be a pimp.
That's not what I'm after in life.
You seem good at it.
But somehow, I'm like bringing people
to you and you're making choices.
I'm sorry that it's turned out
this way on your perfect day.
I do like a massage.
So a six-hander massage.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They just need to be,
it's all about, they
need to be good at it.
These are the best.
It's not about their gender.
It's not about their-
This is the, they are the best.
It's not about how they look.
It's about what they
can do to my body only.
Okay.
And sincerely.
They need to be good with the pressure.
They need to be able to
like stay on that not-
All this is part of it.
Not pop off of it.
Yeah. This is all part of it.
They need to be good.
Okay. We can move on.
Well, shoot. I gotta, man, you're-
So-
You're very good at this.
Yeah.
Jesse's listening.
She's like, well, why is this just once?
So get Mother's Day.
You could be, this could be about me.
It's like, we're digging ourselves a hole.
Okay. We're doing this one.
Like, I'm not doing you right.
So then Christie's like, yeah,
he's saving up his plans for me.
I don't wanna show her that
I'm like really creative
and then I've been holding back on her.
I don't wanna show her
that I'm really creative.
You're really digging a hole.
I love it.
You can't just give up on me now.
You know?
Okay, so what-
Lower the bar.
So what's happening on my,
'cause I'm also at the beach house.
You're at the beach house. Yeah. And then-
Maybe a different day.
You don't like, I think you
like yoga more than a massage.
Are you in, are you really
designing your own day here too?
Is this working for you?
Well, I mean, I expected
there to be some crossover.
To me, it's more about,
at this point for you,
I think when you get off the beach,
like, you've exerted yourself.
The thing you want to do is eat.
Yeah.
So I think that's really-
But I still got that McGriddles
rolling around in there.
I think that's really,
you burned that off, man.
I think you want a, well, I, in one sense,
it's like a buffet.
But you don't, buffet is not classy.
Amen. Classy.
So it's, I mean, if you
all right, so I'm a,
you got, there's a one-way
mirror on the other side of it.
There's like five chefs.
Now you're talking.
Now see, I'm choosing the
masseuse based on skills.
You're choosing the chef based on cuisine.
They're all like six star chefs.
Well, okay, I'm glad you're doing this
but six star is not a thing.
Now, one thing I will
say is one of the best,
I have found that one of
the things I really like is,
and I've only done this like
a couple of times in my life.
I have an idea.
But I went to this,
there was a weird
restaurant on the West Side
where you kind of went into this like mall
and you went up these stairs
and it was kind of like a speakeasy,
and I think I talked
about this on the show.
But there was this weird door
and you like knocked on it.
And then you went into this
Michelin Star restaurant
and the guy, and it was very small.
It could sit like 16 people
and the chef who was this famous chef
who had moved from Chicago to
start this restaurant in LA,
made, did a 12-course meal
and talked to you
personally about each thing.
That's not gonna happen for you.
What? That's what I want.
Here's what's gonna happen.
These six chefs are gonna,
as you're trying to choose-
Are they sick chefs or are they six chefs?
Both.
And as you're trying to
choose which one you want,
you can interview them
through a microphone
that disguises your voice.
One-way mirror.
And they're each like
telling you what they can do.
Because if we install a
one-way mirror in the condo,
we should probably use
it for both the masseuse-
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The yoga thing and the chef thing.
Right, and then, so like,
you've asked them each a few questions,
you've cracked a few jokes.
They're all laughing at your jokes.
I know that's important to you.
I've instructed them
to laugh at your jokes.
I don't wanna be put on the-
Well.
I don't wanna be put on the spot.
You don't know that I've
instructed them to do that.
They're really into your jokes.
I don't like manufactured laughter.
Once you've interviewed all six and like,
you're still kind of torn
because these are all
like top-notch chefs.
Are they telling me like
what the menu options are?
Yeah. They're telling you
whatever you wanna know.
We have a Southwest brush or whatever.
To make your decision.
At that point, they all rush
towards the wall and they
kick it down and they say,
"You don't have to choose.
We're each gonna vie for your approval."
And then the first one brings
out a little morsel and
it describes it and you-
So it's a chef's competition
show and I'm the judge?
Yes, and you're eating it
and you're like cracking a few jokes.
And then-
What does that come from?
The next chef comes out
and is like, topping that.
And like, they're really
competitive with each other.
Is it a show, is this being filmed?
No.
This isn't a pilot?
Okay. I want it to be. I
don't wanna feel any pressure.
This is just for you. This is your day.
Okay.
Nobody's watching.
Are you there?
Yeah.
Where are you?
Getting a massage.
So it's just literally
happening in the same building?
Yeah.
And then, I mean, they're like being,
they're like aggressively
competitive with each other.
Like, they are starting to hate each other
and they're like, you
think they're gonna fight?
And the things they're saying
to each other are just horrible,
but the things they're
saying to you are amazing.
And then it's like, you're
watching a reality show
where they're like,
are they gonna pull each other's hair out?
You know, it's like.
It doesn't have to get violent.
Well, it gets a little trashy.
So this is where the reality
show part of it comes in.
They start making out with
each other in a hot tub.
Okay.
It's like, there's like, you know,
all the things in on those
shows that you watch.
So is one of them like
a "Mail Order Bride"?
Yeah. Mail order chef.
Okay. So we got like "90-Day
Fiance". I like this.
Right, they're like, all
these chefs are just like,
they're either fighting or
they're like making out and-
But they're all making great food?
And they're all making the
best food you ever had.
Hold on.
All different types of cuisines.
I think you may have inadvertently
like created an experience
that I want to actually create for people.
You go to a restaurant and the
people make the food for you
and they're all fighting
and making out and stuff.
Yeah. You like the idea. See.
This is a great, is it-
I know.
Hold on.
Isn't this, this is like,
just going to that
Beverly Hills restaurant
that what's her name owns,
the woman from the show.
Good. Well, I'll just take you there.
What's the show?
"Vanderpump".
Yeah. "Vanderpump."
This is like just going to at least
a Vanderpump's restaurant,
which I've never, can you
believe I've never been there?
Man.
Well, we're going there for dinner.
But I wanna be the only one there.
Right. Shut it down.
Where's my wife?
Because I would want my wife
to be there for that for sure.
Okay.
Fine. She's there, poof.
All of a sudden she's there.
You press a button, you
press the wife button,
she comes up out of the floor.
There's a wife button?
Yeah. Yeah.
And she comes-
You press it, and she comes up
and you press it again, she goes down.
Yeah. Yeah. She's, I
wouldn't call it a cage.
Hey, hey, listen-
But she can't get out.
Listen. Listen, listen, no.
What? I'm just asking.
You're digging holes
for me that I'm not, I don't wanna dig.
You asked for a cage. You
want Jessie to be a cage?
Well, is it like a stripper cage?
I don't know what those are.
If it's like a, if it's
like a sexy stripper cage.
She can get out.
She knows, and of course,
it's not locked from
the outside or anything.
It's all. Yeah.
Yeah. So she can be there.
So that's there.
Okay.
My wife is hanging from a sexy cage.
It doesn't hang, it comes out the floor.
Well, I think once it
comes out of the floor,
then it attaches to
something and then it hangs.
She swings.
That's sexier.
Yeah. Yeah.
And she can get, and she
goes wherever she wants,
she wants to stay up there and dance
or she wants to open the
cage and come sit next to me,
either thing, because
that's her day, you know.
She's, this isn't her perfect,
this is definitely not her perfect day.
No.
But I'm saying,
as she relates to me in my perfect day-
She would enjoy watching this.
She still maintains all her own will.
Okay. And then we gotta get back to you.
So it's a culinary orgy.
Like IFC. Not IFC, UFC.
So they're having sex,
the chefs are having sex?
Well, I don't know what they do
on these trashy shows you watch.
Well, there's nobody filming this.
They could do lots of things.
Hey, it's your day, man.
I don't know about that though.
I don't think they should have sex.
I think they just make out.
I mean, it's up to you, and to them.
Okay.
Like, consent is always a part of this.
Of course.
I know. This is all hypothetical.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Right.
But it is gonna happen.
Okay. So, you know what?
You just called up with my perfect day.
I've surpassed it.
And maybe you've surpassed it.
Yeah.
So now I gotta get back to you.
Now I'm trying to think of,
because I want what I'm gonna,
what I'm sort of requesting
for my day, which I'm now go,
in terms of a categories,
I feel like there's another,
there's an afternoon activity.
And so I'm trying to think
what is the afternoon activity?
You know, first of all,
we haven't even talked
about food yet for you.
So, well, you just want another smoothie?
You just wanna be filled
up with another smoothie,
like a second smoothie?
I mean, I could probably go
for a cheeseburger at this point.
Okay. So you want a cheeseburger?
Yeah. A really good one.
Where from?
Like a, you know, like a Shake Shack.
You want a Shake Shack burger for lunch?
Yeah.
Okay. That could probably be arranged.
All right. Great.
It's a little easier than six chefs
that are gonna screw each
other when they make food.
I said they were gonna fight.
Okay. You're right. Okay. I'm sorry.
I said they were like-
My mind is-
It was very competitive.
It is wandering.
Okay, so what are we gonna do in the,
what are you gonna do in the afternoon?
Now, you're a big mountain biker guy.
I'm very, yeah.
I wouldn't say I'm the best at
it, but I do really enjoy it.
Okay. I can do this.
That's, it's very strenuous though.
I got it for you.
I'm getting a chopper.
There's a helipad on top of the cottage.
We can get a helipad.
We can get one of those Malibu
places that's got a helipad.
This is just one night. We can do that.
And if also, if you're gonna,
I've got the whole six chefs
thing happening on one side-
So it's a helipad.
So it's a big, big-
It's a helicopter with like
a mountain bike attached to it?
Your mountain bike. The pilot shows up.
He's like, "You point at a mountain,
I will take you there, you roll down it,
and then I pick you up and you
point at another mountain."
Wow.
That's what your afternoon is.
That's pretty cool,
man. That's pretty cool.
Do you want a friend?
Do you want your friend, your buddy,
Nick, to come along or do you wanna do it,
'cause he's like, feels
like he might keep you safe?
Sure. Yeah.
Now that you've, I mean, I
can't say no at this point.
He's listening.
Okay. So that's your afternoon.
You can just literally
never have to pedal.
It's just all downhill mountain biking.
But not too aggressive.
What, you point at the mountain.
Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then you tell the
chopper, you're like,
"Anytime I get uncomfortable,
I'm gonna shoot a flare."
You're given a flare and he just comes,
well, you can't shoot a flare
in the mountain in California.
I could be connected by
a tether to the copter
and he could be, so that
way, if I fall off the bike,
it's taught enough that
I don't injure myself.
That'd be cool.
You want a tether?
I want a tether.
I don't know if I can work that out.
I want a chopper tether.
You want a chopper tether?
That sounds like very dangerous.
I don't think I should do the tether.
I'm just saying, 'cause
I think this is feasible.
All right, we got that. So that's good.
Because like, you can go to ski resorts
in the summer and you
can take the lift up,
but that takes time.
Yeah.
And then you're mountain biking back down.
So what are you gonna do next?
What is it you want to do?
I mean, you've just eaten.
You probably wanna go
somewhere and eat again.
No, not yet.
Okay.
I could give you some hints.
I think maybe you wanna,
maybe you want to,
I think you want to go to a place
that no one has access to.
Yes. Exactly! You know me so well.
I was gonna say,
I want to go to a place
that no one has access to.
Really?
Yeah, exactly that.
I love that kind of thing.
So, but I mean, we're talking LA.
There's like parts of,
there's gotta be parts of LA
that nobody, is off limits.
Like if you have to go
through this culvert-
It's definitely underground.
Coming from like the LA River,
and then you're gonna go
underneath Dodger Stadium
where like, you know, Mickey
Rooney had like a lounge.
Sure. Nooks and crannies.
I love nooks and crannies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I don't like some tour guide
and then like a family from Ohio-
So you're given a headlamp and-
To be with me while it's happening.
And a map.
What?
A headlamp and a map.
No, I need a, I want to, I, no.
You do want a guide?
I want a guide. I just
don't want a tour guide.
You know what I'm saying.
I don't, this is not a sanctioned tour.
This is like an expert.
Okay.
Like I read about those
French catacombs under Paris,
or as we say, Paris, and-
There's an LA version of that, I'm sure.
There's gotta be something in LA.
I wanna know that.
I wanna know about this stuff
and I wanna be down there.
I also like visiting places,
like nice places that you, like,
I've always wanted to go
to the Biltmore Estate
with nobody else there, you know?
Okay.
Like.
So you come out of the other
end of the tunnel system.
You may have to take a shower.
We'll have a portable shower for you.
And there will be snacks.
Okay.
Like little smokies.
Like ever so often, the-
Appetizers, yeah.
The, your guide, your Sherpa,
he's gonna give you little smokies.
What about those little meatballs
that your mom makes in the jelly?
Yeah. My mom will make you her meatballs.
She will not be there.
Okay. Cheeseboard.
She gonna have to ship 'em.
All right.
When you come out at the
other end of the tunnel,
it's that, in Beverly Hills,
there's that castle there.
There's that really nice mansion
that you can go and I can't
remember what it's called.
It's like, there's an
estate in Beverly Hills.
You're gonna pop out there
and that's been shut down and you-
Just for me.
You can go around there and you can,
you're gonna find which room
you're gonna have your conjugal visit in.
Okay, so I hit the wife button again.
This is when, hit the wife button,
and she's gonna come out,
she's gonna come up in the-
Okay. This is good.
'Cause I was about, I was thinking,
it's about time for that.
Yeah. Right.
Yeah.
So you come out of the,
I mean the traversing
the tunnel has taken a while.
You're in the like, it's like
the West Coast Build More.
It's in the Beverly Hills.
How come I don't know about this?
Look that up. I don't know what it is.
It's like some sort of
estate mansion Beverly Hills.
This sounds cool, man.
Yeah, and then it's like,
you can, any bed you want,
any hard surface, multiple surfaces.
We can make love in multiple rooms.
Yeah. Yep.
Okay.
You and your wife, just to clarify.
Yeah, yeah.
I will not be there.
My wife and I will make
love in multiple rooms.
Right.
It's like, you never know what they can do
with the edit of this thing.
Yeah. Right.
They edit this stuff down.
Yeah. Yeah.
They put it on TikTok.
The Tumblr folks will
have a ball with that one.
Put it on TikTok. They put it on Twitter.
Are you finding it?
Greystone.
Greystone. Greystone?
Greystone Mansion.
Greystone mansion.
Mansion?
Mansion.
You'll love it.
Okay.
The gardens are even amazing.
I was gonna say, I love gardens.
Well, you know, you could have a little.
I'm a sucker for gardens,
man. Huntington Gardens.
Have a little smoke break in the gardens.
I spend all day there.
But it's the part I don't
like is the other people.
No other people are there.
I love this.
Get lost in the hedges.
Yes.
And then-
Can the six chefs come
back to the mansion?
Nope. No, that's over.
That's over.
It's never gonna be as good
as it was the first time.
Okay. Well, what's the new food?
Well, you know what?
Hold on. So yeah. Okay.
We're not to that.
Yeah, 'cause I've got
you in mountain biking,
you've had a tough day.
I need, I really need, yeah.
I might need to get cleaned up.
Well, after you've,
what's the coolest way to
get cleaned up, you know?
Like, what's the most enjoyable
way to get cleaned up?
Sponge bath.
Hot tub.
Hot tub, okay.
So, okay.
I'm not in a convalescent home.
That's simple .
You come back to the-
Sponge bath.
You come back.
You gonna go to a new place.
Do you wanna go to a new place?
'Cause I can rent two places.
Yeah. I don't wanna go back to that place.
Yeah. That place is old. Old news now.
They kicked the wall down.
It's like it's in shambles.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. That place
is a piece of crap now.
Yeah.
Don't wanna go back to it.
So we're going to a new place.
You know, I kind of feel
like you might be ready
for like a little bit of a crowd.
You know, like you may want to go a party
of your handpicked friends and-
I think it's too early for that.
That, it's still daylight.
I was thinking this is
like five or six o'clock.
No, it's, I'm trying to create
a dinner situation for you.
Yeah. I gotta eat something.
A dinner and evening situation.
Well, I mean, I did give
you a hint in your thing.
I kind of need my version of-
You have to hit the wife button too.
Yeah.
And okay, well, I mean that's easy.
Afternoon delight, they call it.
It, I think at one of the
tops of the mountains,
because you like to have sex outdoors,
your wife is there on one of
those blankets that y'all like.
Okay.
I mean, maybe there's a-
And because Christie is-
A yurt.
And because Christie is
scared, just logistics,
I hate to go off on logistics,
because Christie is scared of flying,
she's been sedated like BA Baracus.
Oh God.
And she's-
She's tethered down from the 'copter?
Well-
She fall floppy.
I'm just saying she didn't know,
like she knew she was gonna be
at the top of the mountain
and she's now there
and she's awake when you show up.
Well, she's gonna be groggy, man.
I'm just saying, no, no.
Well, I'm just saying
she's totally at ease
because she was sedated.
What, you're doing it again.
This is such a, there's no
need to go down this path.
I'm just saying-
Drugging my own wife for a conjugal visit.
No, no, no.
It's unnecessary and seems wrong.
You're using, the terms
you're using are all wrong.
I'm saying that-
The writing's on the wall, man.
Okay. Better idea.
You roll down. This is good.
You pick, there's one mountain.
I don't think I'm gonna take
the bike down the last time.
No, no, but you know-
I am gonna come down,
but I'm gonna come down on something else.
A horse?
Yeah. Really? That's a good idea.
Well, what were you thinking?
A horse.
Okay.
Imma gallop down the mountain on a horse.
You come down the mountain
on a horse that has been sedated
and put at the top of the mountain.
I mean it's, somebody's
gotta get sedated here,
just logistically, okay?
I mean-
And then you come down.
Someone else could have ridden it up.
Right, but here's,
this is where the Beverly
Hills aspect comes in for you.
So have you noticed that like
when you're hiking up
in like Runyon canyon
and that part of town,
there's these super rich people
who have these giant estates
and they've got like trails that come
off of the main trail and you can-
Yeah.
So you horse it down one of these trails
and you go into like the nicest backyard
that I can get somebody
to agree to let me in.
And we have created a scene where it looks
like you are riding your horse
into the garden of Eden, okay?
So I'm naked?
You're, well, you have a
choice to do what you want,
but your wife is only wearing
fig leaves, and she is there.
She's surrounded by fruit.
Do fig leaves get sticky or just the figs?
She's surrounded by figs and
she's wearing fig leaves.
Great.
Leaves.
She's like Eve, right?
Yeah.
And we've got the garden of Eden theme
in the back and there's,
and we've got trained animals in pairs.
Okay.
So a little Noah's Ark too.
I'm just throwing a lot
of biblical references.
Okay. Yeah.
Because you're gonna get to know her
in the biblical sense in the
back of this backyard, okay?
So you come down and you're
washed in a very, you know.
I get off the horse and I'm like,
I'm being like hosed down.
There's a group of people who drop
you into a bath to like a
clawfoot tub with heated water.
Like just kind of a,
it's a little bit of a hot tub situation.
Okay. Yeah.
Getting you ready.
You know, like getting the,
this is like getting the king
ready to go into the room.
Milk bath?
Any kind of liquid you want
that I can get hold of.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Except mercury.
And then you have an outdoor
visit with your wife.
The horse turns around, turns away.
Okay.
The horse doesn't watch.
Nothing makes me horny like looking
at the ass end of a horse.
And then-
I don't care if the horse watches.
Okay.
And then from there is
where we start moving
into the evening activities.
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay?
Well, you're skipping a step here.
No, I gotta clean up.
No.
I mean the perfect day for
me has to include a nap.
Okay, well, you make love
and you fall asleep in your wife's arms.
Yeah.
Outside.
We've got like mosquito candles
so you're not gonna
get bitten by anything.
No, no, no.
You can sleep outside.
There's a breeze.
It's exactly the breeze that you want.
Okay. You take a nap.
Like a 90-minute nap.
As long as you want.
Yeah. I mean, I'm willing to give
up 90 minutes of my perfect
day to just be in Slumberland.
Okay. Back to me. What
are you doing for me?
Where did we leave you off?
You're in the-
I'm in the Greystone
mansion by myself, lost.
Link, where are you?
It's taken us 90 minutes.
No, no.
So you gotta wait for 90 minutes.
For me to wake up.
I'm with my wife.
We've made love in every
room, if I can do that.
Well, you'll be allowed to,
but you won't be, you may not be capable.
We've made room in. We made
love in half of the rooms,
however far I got.
You did not pull that off.
Okay.
It's the thought that counts, you know.
I have a very specific idea
of what I want to happen now.
I mean-
Just so you know.
You're gonna get into an outfit.
Like I think the outfit matters to you.
The outfit matters to me.
I'm not the one wearing
matching suits in the,
doing the DJ set.
Hey, I'm just, I'm playing in seeds.
Okay, you're right. I'm
in an outfit. Got it.
Yeah. You're in your outfit.
It's got a big collar.
Okay.
What, what?
Well, there's something,
there's a place I'm trying to lead you.
What have I been talking about lately
is what I want to do as I get older
and also when I wanna start doing
like on a semi-regular
basis here in LA with?
Pedicures.
Your toes need work, man.
No. Socially.
Okay.
So you want to have afternoon
coffee with an author?
No, no, no, no.
I told you about my idea for these,
me engineering these social.
Yeah, soirees, like a
conversational soiree where-
And I gave you the example
of the one that I heard about
my wife share with me on Twitter
'cause she knows I'm into this idea
and I'm trying to begin
curating these experiences.
I'm really into this idea.
Well, was I inebriated
when you told me this?
Now hold on. I'll remember it.
I've talked about it multiple times.
Yeah. This is a themed
party with an assignment.
And you want me to take your idea
as if it's mine and then
give it back to you?
Well-
'Cause I remember it.
Well, my idea-
Don't, you can't say it.
No, it's not-
I'm planning your perfect day.
It's not my idea.
The example idea was somebody
on Twitter who already did it.
Rhett is going to show up
at an amazing event space
and let you know what, we've
been, you're in the hills.
I'm trying to figure
out where the locale is.
I think you're on a rooftop
event space as the sun sets
where the most interesting people
that fascinate you show
up from all walks of life
and they've each prepared
their assignment,
which is a PowerPoint presentation.
Okay .
I think you have to, can
I just give the context?
Because I think you-
It's an-
I wanna give the context
and I want you to come up with the,
what I want you to do is
come up with the theme.
Okay, whatever. Plan your day, man.
No, no. I want you to come
up with what the theme is 'cause-
Go ahead. Go ahead.
Okay, so I told my wife,
I've been talking about this,
that as I get older, one of
the things I'm interested
in doing is curating
social settings for people
to do weird things in that are
just funny and interesting.
Now this is why we have
game night in our house,
which we haven't had since the pandemic.
But like the reason we have it
is I love like getting people together,
eating something interesting or fun
and then doing something fun together.
And I just kind of, I love partaking,
but I also just kind of love curating
it and watching it happen, right?
Yeah.
And my wife sent me this Twitter post
where a woman was like,
I just went to something
called Parm and PowerPoint.
Right.
Where the theme of the
party was you show up
and everyone eats chicken
parm and then everyone
has prepared a short
PowerPoint presentation
in a niche area of their knowledge.
And when you get there,
they mix 'em all up
and you have to do the
PowerPoint presentation-
Of somebody else.
From somebody else
for the whole group.
Isn't that brilliant? Ain't that so fun?
And I love this. I love this kind of.
I've come up with one that
I'm calling Milk Shakespeare.
That's my first idea,
where we all have alcoholic milkshakes.
And then we all are given assignments
and you divide up into small groups
and you do Shakespeare themed plays
of with a theme and like a
rule, like a stipulation.
Like you draw a theme and a stipulation
then you go with your little group
and you write it and then you come
and I'll perform it inebriated
with each other on these drunk milkshakes.
So that's-
Okay, on these drunk milkshakes.
I'm gonna do that for our
game night by the way.
Do you feel like you can't
just do the PowerPoint thing
'cause I, that's also-
No, I want you to come up with a new one
because you're planning my day.
I don't, I can't do Parm and PowerPoint
because that's already been done.
Every time I do it,
it's gonna be different.
And I got this vision.
When I'm old, I just wanna
have a place where, again,
it makes me sound like a pimp.
I don't, I'm not trying to sound
like a pimp or like Hugh
Hefner or something,
but I just wanna be an old
guy who curates experiences.
You wanna be a king. Right?
And then I sit in the corner,
smoking a pipe and I'm like,
this is a great PowerPoint.
You know, I just wanna,
I just love the idea of
people doing crazy stuff.
The Shakespeare resonates
with a different type
of person than the PowerPoint.
That's the beauty of it.
And so then over time, I just don't think,
I think the PowerPoint
should still be on the table.
That's my humble request
is that you say, hey-
You start with PowerPoint?
That's a good one too, man.
It is. It's better than
the Milk Shakespeare.
Yeah. I think it's
better than Shakespeare,
but that's just my personal preference.
Like Jenna likes the Shakespeare.
She likes Milk Shakespeare.
But like getting together
and doing drama stuff is,
it's an acquired taste for some people.
But-
And, but so is giving a PowerPoint.
But I love watching people come
out of their shell and do things like-
Unless they don't.
But when you have a PowerPoint,
like you have some structure
and then if you're struggling
through it, it's still there.
You have a backbone that's like.
Yeah, yeah, or we just come
up with a whole new one.
Yeah. Like Sausage and Sashay.
Yeah. Whatever that is. Yeah.
It's when when you eat
sausages and then you have to-
Do a little sashay?
You have to do a little,
you have to invent a dance.
Invent a dance.
But the brilliance is that
you've prepared something
that then somebody else gets.
Like that's what really puts
the parm and PowerPoint over the top.
The moment that you told
me that they switch 'em up,
it became a brilliant idea because they-
Yeah, that's what makes it great.
Everybody is out of their
comfort zone equally,
give or take.
What I'm telling you is
that, that is an idea.
And there are an unlimited,
infinite number of great ideas.
Well, you actually thought about it
and only came up with
Shakes and Shakespeare.
Shakes, Milk Shakespeare.
And-
And that's the, I mean, now
just I farted that idea.
I'm just wanna saying,
like, do you know that movie about-
There's something else you could prepare.
What's the name of that movie
where the woman marries into the family
and they have her over at the house
and then they try to kill her?
It's a horror movie that's kind of funny.
But like that family has this
crazy thing that they do.
I don't wanna do that 'cause
I don't want anybody to die,
but like I've always loved
the idea of like these,
even if it's like a murder
mystery kind of thing.
Yeah.
But,
and I've never been been to one,
and I've never been a part of one.
So I wanna go to like the
most awesome version of that.
That's how I want to end my day
with the people that I love.
I love that.
And then also some just interesting people
who you might be able to get to show up.
Yeah.
You might have to pay 'em.
I definitely like,
like I like dinner with
some close friends.
We're now planning our own days,
but then move into something
that's more of an event.
Well, do you want to
just maybe our days end
at this event together?
Yeah. I like that.
That's sweet.
Parm and PowerPoint.
Or something better that
we haven't thought of yet.
Yeah. Switching it up
is what's so brilliant.
Yeah, but the, I'm just saying,
that was a great idea, but
we can have a better idea.
You wanna take credit for the idea.
No, I'm just saying,
I like the idea of every
time people show up-
It's different.
I get that.
Okay, so you've recovered
from making love with
your wife in the garden.
I've recovered from making love
with my wife in multiple
rooms in a mansion.
We are taken to, with our wives,
to this incredible event space
where we meet the friends that we love.
And then some like
other interesting people
that have been paid off to be there.
Yeah, like an author.
Yeah.
A scientist.
Somebody who studied
something really interesting.
Yeah, like a highly rated plumber.
Yeah. No influencers.
No influencers.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Stay away from them.
Yeah.
And you know what, every,
all the chefs can show up.
The chefs come back.
And like the masseuses and yoga people.
They're all there.
Like the guy, everybody's here.
It's like the end of a movie.
Yeah.
Yeah, the helicopter pilot comes in.
Yeah, yeah.
The horse.
Yes, the horse is there.
The horse is inside.
People are like riding the horse.
This is such a big house.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah. This is great.
The horse is there. I love that.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And we, and it, this goes into, like-
This goes until we pass out.
To like three in the morning.
Yeah.
I'm not big into passing out.
I don't ever get so drunk that I pass out.
In fact, it's never happened, but I think-
Yeah, I'm not, I've never done
it either and I don't wanna.
I think I might do it tonight.
I don't want.
I mean, not tonight.
On this night, I might get
so drunk that I pass out.
I don't want the day after my perfect day
to be the worst day.
Well, one of those masseuses comes
up and like hooks you up to like an IV
and gives you a vitamin B shot in your ass
and stuff as you go to sleep.
You'll be fine.
Okay. All right.
Hey, that's it.
We ended it. That was fun, man.
I mean, part of it, there's
a therapy to this, like.
We gotta do this now.
Part of it made me feel
like I experienced it.
Yeah.
Like, I actually feel some endorphins.
I feel some psychosomatic
positivity. This has been good.
Yeah, man.
Don't blow it with your Rec.
And I feel like we could engineer
at least a portion of that, you know?
Yeah. I think we could.
It's like, why not make that happen?
Why not make that a reality?
Yeah.
Okay, 1-888-EARPOD1.
Call in and let us know
what you think about that.
I have a Rec that is a little unusual.
And my Rec, ironically,
is that I think if you have
something that's hurting on you,
you should go to the doctor.
And this is why I'm gonna, this
is why I'm telling you this.
See?
So I think I've disclosed
that my right shoulder
has been bothering me.
And if, and it's been
bothering me for like 15 years.
Like I haven't been able to really throw
a baseball in the same way.
You can see that in the evidence
of when we threw the pitches
out at the Dodger Stadium
and mine bounced before
it got to the plate.
'Cause I was kind of, I can't,
I can't get my arm back anymore.
And, you know, but I'm not,
I don't need to throw
things very often, right?
And so it's just kind of like,
this is just something I'll deal with.
I don't wanna go to the doctor
'cause I don't want them to tell me
that I need surgery 'cause
I'm not gonna get surgery,
and what else am I gonna do?
So I went to an orthopedist
who was like, you know,
"I think you should just,
we should just do a few weeks of physical,
you know, like six weeks
of physical therapy."
Yeah.
To see if that starts fixing things.
And I went to a physical
therapist who really got committed
to trying to figure out what was wrong.
Very much like I, you probably had
a tear at some point and
it's kind of stiffened
up here in the back
and you've got some impingement, whatever.
Long story short is that
I've just been doing these exercises.
And like with every day that passes,
the mobility comes back, right?
What?
It's that simple.
I talked about going
to the physical therapist
and fixing my shoulder.
I've talked about going
to a physical therapist
all the time on this show.
I, well, I understand
that. But for some reason-
I was recommending it
constantly by implying it.
But for some reason I, well, first of all,
I've always known that
I should be doing this.
Yeah.
But, and the reason I'm making
it a Rec is because somebody out there,
this is like one of those preachers,
somebody out there right
now, you hear, you hear-
Needs to go to physical therapy.
This is for you.
You need to come up front
and give your life to Jesus.
Give your to the physical therapist.
What you need to do actually
is you need to go to the doctor.
If you've got something that's like,
that's kind of bothering me a little bit.
This is a funny rec, man.
Just go.
Go to the doctor.
You know? Go to the
doctor, get it checked out.
Because sometimes this as simple as here's
a list of exercises that you can do
that are going to improve your life.
And maybe you'll, I might even be throwing
a baseball in a few weeks.
Hey,
Who knows, man?
What a great day.
I just had a great day.
Hashtag #earbiscuits.
1-888-EARPOD1.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.